foreign
opens two layers deep into its movie
within a TV show being filmed cliche
forcing me to think about how painful
that tattoo on your hand must have been
to get and I don't appreciate it if you
hadn't broken into that DHS Mainframe
true I am hell of a hacker
I'm no hero we get it it's a bad big
budget movie being produced by an evil
big budget Corporation and the boys is a
good big budget show being produced by a
Maybe not evil big budget Corporation
there's a Nuance here that I don't have
the time or motivation to unpack so in
the end I'm just gonna say that this
whole thing feels like the pot calling
the kettle a wanker also seen where
someone says hell of a hacker does not
contain an Angelina Jolie look at these
strong female lesbians Homeland I really
is just an oxymoron isn't he so well
they're all starving but one of them's
got a [__] cell phone down playing
the economic impact of technological
leapfrogging being the tall guy standing
in the front of the pit don't get me
wrong I'm empathetic to your situation
you want to get a close-up look at Harry
Styles just like the rest of us
unfortunately there are 40 people behind
you that are now your mortal enemies in
plotting your demise so the sin is that
slow and calculated Vengeance that I
hope never catches up with you man we
are tripling down here we've got the
forlorn look the cigarette and the shot
of what I can only assume is bourbon how
else would we ever know that Billy's two
seconds away from being a blubbering
mess because his wife wasn't okay with
him killing her child fought Fresh Farms
come on vod's more of an [__] behind
the [__] they'd have a subsidiary for
this thinking I'd be distracted by these
Werther's Originals it worked hey
hey sorry I thought I was getting a
voicemail admitting to someone you were
hoping you could leave them a message
instead of actually having to you know
talk to them what are you watching a
show called eat my dick thinking that
title would make anyone less interested
in what you're watching you're a Site
for Sore Eyes oh hey it's that guy from
Heroes whose power I can't remember and
he's been in a bunch of other stuff too
but all I remember is Heroes a Legacy
isn't always something you get to choose
clearly you like me you've been I've
seen me like a lovesick stand girl all
day lovesick stand girls have been
accused of a lot of things but simply
liking something is not one of them
banana salt water taffy so this is where
it all comes to
himself for a few drops of piss hey you
don't know what the guy did to end up in
that Hoveround he might have done a sick
[Music]
jumping Americans
any personal growth that could have
occurred from this impassioned debate
about the artistic choices made in the
production of Hamilton immediately gets
his face ripped off Boy Billy you should
have told me you were bringing company
who's this one remind you of boy are we
really to believe the Billy's drug
dealing Anne is letting strangers into
her home just because they said they
were friends of his oy old people are
just as bad as kids what are you doing
here Huey he heard a dog toy on the
phone but how did Huey know it was a toy
specifically for her dog babies and
toddlers have squeaky toys as well
they're the toys your sisters get for
your newborn child because they hate you
it never wants you to get any sleep
again just so you know
that's Tara's girlfriend what he's pink
he always been holding this thing the
whole scene and the only reason Judy
didn't mention this earlier is that the
writers know you can't have an old woman
say without a bit of foreplay first
having your mirror pointed up in a way
that you can see black noir on the roof
is convenient and completely useless for
driving also episode never confirms
whether or not black noir actually
thinks this is hiding ma'am do you have
any nails ball bearings electrical
wiring pressurized aerosol products I
need a can about this big turns out that
asking the teacher this on the first day
of second grade is a good way to force
your parents to move to a different
School District she's
bravemave
we're recommending a multi-pronged image
makeover this is some top tier satire
about corporations shamelessly latching
on to anything in the public
Consciousness and exploiting it just to
make a buck Grand Marshals at the New
York and Chicago Pride because you are
two proud lesbians and Malcolm Barrett
makes it just as funny as it is critical
so go ahead and take your sin back that
looks like menswear Pew research shows
that two feminine women in a
relationship sends a problematic message
yeah this isn't Penthouse Forum it's
definitely not because this is something
that even Penthouse Forum would turn
their nose up at seriously not a single
person just happens to look up and spot
in a war is this right
just like homologous way less delightful
yeah the less delightful home alone
already has a title and that title is
saw and I don't think you want to play
that game Huey unless of course you know
how to get a bear trap off your head
without ripping your jaw off on the
process and in less than 60 seconds that
Ninja's here for me the thing I said to
my mom when Josh Billings showed up at
our house on the Halloween of 1996
somehow makes it into the episode it
ain't that kind of massage parlor the
thing I said to Josh Billings in the
summer of 2016 when I invited him out
for a spa day somehow makes it into the
episode I know the rage you feel but
this
not the way says the man who assisted in
full-on murdering one of the seven this
is poison for your soul no the best
poison for your soul Frenchie is every
rose has its thorn I'd also accept
Unskinny Bop he'll be a monster once
again says the guy who assisted in
full-on murdering one of the seven
remember when you were young and the
world was full of possibilities
purchasing this domain but then proving
your creative bankruptcy by just having
a redirect to the Sony Pictures website
everyone in that City ate my paella my
grandmother's paella also brings all the
boys to the yard the guy with
elephantitis I've gotten something
horribly wrong here I think it's time
that I stay put for a while but why are
they letting the public know a train is
retiring in a [__] movie or whatever
this is movie they're [__] filming
instead of saving the lives of whomever
happens to be in danger today seeing
does not contain one Edna Mode but if
you've served with our amazing soldiers
like I have you would know that freedom
comes at a price you don't speak for us
can't believe I'm someone taking
homelander's side in anything but
technically he's not speaking for the
military he's sharing his own experience
while he's been working alongside the
military and seeing them in action
anyone who's ever watched this TV show
or any TV show knows this isn't
something that's actually happening so
there is no suspense and I have to ask
why is this laser ring like for reals
black noir is still not being noticed
titties do not need a committee the
board or a deliberative assembly you
leave the titties alone putting a full
pineapple in this packed ass fruit bowl
can I ask you something asking someone a
question about whether or not you can
ask them a question all right you [__]
where are you why is Noir even hiding if
those explosions didn't hurt him why
would he be concerned about butcher
being able to fight him so you wanna
take me on do you this is why we love
Billy so much he's not afraid to stand
up to power and face impossible odds but
it's also increasingly more [__]
every time he survives one of these
interactions I've got storm front flying
in Miss Turner phrase is incredibly
deceiving when the person can actually
fly apparently the cinematographer's
superpower in this scene was the male
super gays guessing a password right
based on the convenient clue right next
to the computer is convenient this is
why when setting your passwords you'll
get five different things in the room
and create a word mashup of all of them
substituting numbers for some of the
letters and this is why you forget that
password five minutes later and have to
reset it every time you need to log in
she didn't just lie to me about compound
V okay she lied to me about everything
man starlight's taking that there is no
Santa Claus seriously you are killed a
[__] Swinton she's obviously giving
off more of a Meryl Streep Vibe and you
know that Stormfront lightning really
doesn't strike twice Roy Sullivan
deniers I do like you you
spunk telling a grown adult they have
spunk I've got you something Tara [__]
it
That's My Boy writers think the terror
would just start humming the first
stuffed animal he sees when we all know
a gentleman of his caliber values a
proper courtship how is the group
posting up on the side of the road like
this not suspicious to that cop over
there in the background
[Music]
not being sure whether you're [__] or
fighting and just settling on the answer
of yes
it's a laser beam hey train you're out
out of what or out of beer I really wish
you had clear this with me before you
went over there this is your fault you
lie me
the money bed my friend
hello hello
[Music]
what are you watching
the show called watch that but how are
you gonna get through all of them don't
worry
she's got Hills
you've been I [__] me like a lovesick
stand girl all day why is that
Ray I didn't come here to jump your
bones okay what do you think
a pieces from the forest